hello and welcome to zero playing
cowboys diva a German account okay it's
pretty new book out maybe I don't know
games a recent yeah let's see what
happens um it means cowboy boots by the
way the Catalan mm-hmm yeah okay I
really should look for something else
than the bogo set up not that I think
it's so bad I just said I want to have a
little bit more of a variety I forgot e5
again I have to play that earlier
constantly making that mistake ok ok
this is sometimes an idea and playing
the Bishop to c5 and see
it's very uncommon but it's interesting
or think King getting this in
oh it's taking Wow hey I didn't expect
at all so what is the idea wants to play
with a five-year menial I could be six
than day five hmm that's not a problem
the same i also have 94 TM yep I think I
think I'll do that he more or less has
to play and should to you one okay if
I'm retreat it's not so great so let's
take it and now yeah I don't mind that
at all that have to be 6 s all that I
from f5 plate now I think I'll do p 6
it's got that if he will play a 45 no or
very soonish after Bishop d7 at least
hmm yeah it looks very comfortable for
black I can also allow him to take I
mean this is not totally totally
terrible but thinking about that is
probably probably taking too long okay
hmm seems he is very keen on getting
that porn back I don't know it takes a
long time I think I'll try to use that
for some attack here Bishop f5 should
reform for possible f3h three losses due
to F takes 2-3 immediately it's easy
enough for him to make a move but should
be four maybe no Bishop before by ok ok
I can take out you I can take a take you
to okay that's not working either hmm
it's a bit uncomfortable then
yeah okay i'm doing this let's not spend
too much time here and just play it
simple
ok yeah I can go to deform
hmm yeah it's a bit of a problem if I
want to play for win and I really want
to do that don't want to draw here now
he wants a draw ok I would have got to
be six now if he would have continued to
earn repeat yeah my I can pile up yeah
it looks nice but it's not clear that
i'm having having some powerful
continuation here for cannot take you to
h3
when ideas okay Queen threatening age
three now this sir might become
dangerous fan I mean okay it is
dangerous fine that much is clear but
i'm not sure if how good it is and he
just takes everything here hopes for the
best check okay let's do this and now
how to how to do that to get on light
square
guru gave heed of course I don't have to
play I just want to take the five years
the idea and now i can take f2 right
time morning let's take retina queen bee
one now could be one what are you doing
about it King cannot move g4 doesn't
help he also has to keep avoid every
cupboard mmm don't see it at the moment
don't see it you should be four they
still queen bee one
and I don't see a defense don't see it
yeah okay I can take the i dunno then he
has some green capture by check whenever
gave six wait let's check for now I
think I just have to go with us now okay
I wanted to check check Andrew have six
just hope there is no magic
counter-attack van rook c8 27 or
something okay check check okay
white resigns Joe very I clear very
unclear stuff I'm I felt that I should
be in good shape but it's it's also my
natural optimism probably okay so this
and this looks it looks risky really
does shouldn't you follow k the computer
says that black is a lot better here so
my hunch wasn't totally and totally off
it wants to play green g5 though now
Queen g5 Wow minus 1.5 that looks scary
or sounds scary the don't quite get us
is this here the engine wants to play
cupid Jeff I ok it's a tempo it's a
tempo ok now it's very dangerous 25 is a
good idea probably better than this oops
Oh Bishop f5 is given by the comp for
Bishop d3 yet this means the material
right had that's true the rook it
doesn't have good squares something like
this I'm winning the exchange many
whites got pawns but it's maybe not
enough very interesting and we had this
yeah I would have if he would have
repeated here I would have gone to be 6
and yeah tough position ya hear the
computer assesses this is equal it wants
to play Bishop c3 returning the pawn I
can take here a couple of times take a
tube which is probably equal indeed yes
yeah probably
TM I'm having some pressure now I look
fa it is also good yeah this is this the
computer does not believe in for me okay
now it switches and now it switches to a
black advantage hmm Queen f7 is the
engine move try to grab the five is that
bad though you should have played this
move because Luke g5 there is the check
and you have eight very interesting I
have this miracle that just about saves
the day but just not better for black
computer says equal so this is what he
should have done just retreat the TA
it's losing right yeah this is I didn't
see a defense and it is losing yeah yeah
Group D hi and I saw the move but I also
saw that this should win so what doesn't
win oh wow why doesn't that when rookie
to this is my rookie towards saving
white cool aha
yeah the engine gets black just a small
advantage it still looks very
threatening and now no the computer
computers advantage for black is growing
I don't know maybe there is something
deep deep down here that is still
something I mean that that point is very
problematic especially in a practical
game but hmm tough okay they're all
interesting game though thanks for
watching